m
21 janvier 1793 louis saez et guillotiné
184 ans plus tard comme chaque année une
messe à sa mémoire a été célébrée dans
plusieurs villes de france ainsi qu'à
paris dans l'église de saint-germain
l'observance
[Musique]
vous êtes monarchiste
six monarchies
depuis quand
partir du moment où on a conscience de
ce qu'est exactement l'histoire de
france on aime en schiste fait le
problème mathématique je veux dire que
43 ans bien en dix siècles valent plus
que bientôt six républiques en 200 ans
voilà c'est pour parce que je suis
nationaliste u monarchie
parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
faux c'est un
une idée que j'ai qui est très actuel et
ce que je pense je suis très
profondément royalistes mais je sais pas
vous est demandé pourquoi j'avais rétro
trois intérêts de moi que je suis dit
m'avez-vous collaboration est un peu
passéistes bon produit tout regarder
cette église et l aigle et des rois de
france lui l'ailé droite france est
terminée depuis 200 ans mais ils ont
tout de même créé la france oui la
france n'existe plus depuis qu'il n'y a
plus droit je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
souvenirs des rois de france ne
serait-ce qu ici et partout dans toute
la france ils ont eux mêmes créé
l'essentiel oui mais nous vivons en
république depuis 200 ans et la majorité
des gens est satisfait ou soit du fait
ça c'est à dire un quand vous parlez
l'élan à la fois beaucoup de gens qui
sont encore donc le des sentiments
allemand mais enfin qui se rappelle
quand même de la royauté
pas l'impression d'appartenir à une
minorité aussi bien sûr c'est certain
mais une minorité qui est même très
importante parce que elle permet de
faire une critique et 2 de ces réagir un
peu les gens en asie n'avez vous pas
l'impression que tous les gens qui sont
ici sur un peu les défenseurs d'une
cause perdue non pas du tout c'est la
cause de l'avenir
[Musique]
moi qui suis un vieux royalistes puis 50
ans un ancien camelots du roi ça fait
plaisir de voir les jeunes qui continue
la tradition
la tradition c'est quelque chose de très
vivant et justement c'est ce qui donne
toute sa valeur la monarchie pour
préserver la famille la patrie et le
travail louis celle en haut elle avait
supprimé en france la torture il avait
aboli la peine de mort il a fallu les
grands ancêtres pour la pourrait
rétablir la peine de mort n'êtes vous
pas êtes vous partisan d'al maintenant
je suis partisan mademoiselle de la
peine de mort contre les assassins et
boussès des dépenses des assassins la
sueur addition si vous voulez c'est
garder ce qui est bon du passé et le
faire perdurer et progresser pour de
nouvelles choses parce que ça dure et
des exemples est dedans on crève de
conservatisme depuis 200 ans c'est à
dire depuis la révolution française on
n'a jamais trouvé en fait un régime
stable nous en sommes à la cinquième
république et on cherche toujours une
constitution valable croyez vous que la
démocratie soit le rêve on croyait plus
que c'est le système qui est parfait le
blé mocratie vous êtes hostile au
suffrage universel à leurs frais le
suffrage universel dans les communes
dans les communes à l'échelon natale et
à l'échelon on connaît les personnes
d'accord je trouve que l'une de ses
phrases universel dans les municipalités
par exemple simplement parfait ça
existait d'ailleurs du temps des rois
[Musique]
nous voudrions changé c'est pour ça que
nous sommes réactionnaire fois la
monarchie n'est pas une question de
place je crois j'ai fait grand cas des
mulliez qui ne sont absolument pas les
meilleurs royalistes milieu tout à fait
un ouvrier et j'arrive à partager mes
idées reçues sur la le mot privilège n'a
pas une nuance péjorative comme on
l'entend république mais il représente à
mon sens simplement une loi adaptée aux
nécessités de leur présence moi j'ai mon
arbre généalogique que je produis
refusait xiiie siècle moselle et dans
les autres sont bons à rien j'ai jamais
dit ça mais les autres comme dans une
famille il faut apprendre à vieillir un
pays comme on apprend un client dans une
moiteur aux ancêtres en 1793 quelle
importance telle importance mais
mademoiselle l'important c'est que ce le
pays est à ce qu'ils ont fait et non pas
ceux qui viennent du fin fond de la
roumanie de la lettonie et de
l'allemagne vive le roi avant la
république
[Musique]
le château déchets rei de la rivière ce
21 janvier 1989
on commémore sous le regard du petit
louis 17 le 21 janvier 1793 date de
l'exécution louis saez ici on et
monarchistes légitimiste bon catholique
est épris de tradition de père en fils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez ces gens là monsieur on vilipende
la gueuse entendez la république un peu
provocateur l'année du bicentenaire
ce bicentenaire du diable est notre
chance et pensez vous sincèrement que la
majorité des français a besoin ou envie
d'un roi eh bien je ne dirais pas cela
je ne crois pas que là pour l'instant
les français ont envie d'un mois il dira
il en rêve de plus en plus je ne crois
pas être un phénomène si demain vous
aviez un enfant est ce que vous
supporteriez qu'ils soient républicains
enfants il serait certainement
royalistes parce que les enfants bien
élevés ressent leur temps et mes grands
parents
et mes arrière grands pères et grand
mère m'ont appris la royauté
et c'est quoi la royauté la royauté ses
silences éloquents malgré un sens inné
de la famille décidément la monarchie
n'est plus ce qu'elle était le château
familial est cerné d'un caravaning
férocement république
particulier à particules
héritier de charles maurras
jeune fille poudret et collier de perles
anciens de la restauration nationale
nostalgique de la fleur de lys communion
solennelle en la chapelle expiatoire
messe en latin pour un souverain
guillotiné le 21 janvier 1793
depuis les royalistes ne s'en sont
jamais tout à fait remis notre chère
patrie la france le plus beau royaume
sous le soleil et la loi salique le
spécifie nettement n'a pas être
gouvernés par des assassins et des
voleurs notre jeunesse est perdu la
france est perdu il faut la sauver il
faut vider ce palais bourbon de tous et
l'a6 et
l'a7 l'idée d'une france unie rassemblée
grâce à une personne
un certain système politique est une
chose importante et c'est cela que je
viens commémorer albert de sean
descendants lointains du baron de sean
anobli par maximilien premier d'autriche
il y a six siècles chez le baron on est
respectueux des traditions de génération
en génération
c'est une tradition comporte dans le
caire et que l'on mène dans sa vie
d'honneur de religion parce que le roi
représente tout de même c'est un être
sacré où les français se sont mis autour
sur les cinq républiques nous avons eu
deux sont des pastiches la troisième
était fait pour un droit constitutionnel
c'est un président qui t'arrive est pour
ça qu on a sept ans de présidence est
aujourd'hui bien nous avons un roi est
lui bien qu'elle est différent sur le
marché de monarchie constitutionnelle
le mouvement royaliste aujourd'hui
divisée et affaiblie reste pour quelques
centaines de militants une école de
formation politique qui prône le
nationalisme intégral la crise des
valeurs a fait de ces jeunes des
royalistes de conviction pour un jeune
les années 90 la monarchie reste un
idéal pour l'asie la monarchie en vie
siècle a donné l'exemple d'un régime
équilibré d'un régime stable la régime
quasiment miraculeusement préservée des
germes de la tyrannie d'un régime
toujours profondément humain même
humaniste et d'un régime qui à mon avis
appareils comme le recours à la fin d'un
siècle marqué par une barbarie sans
précédent et par une haie floraison sans
précédent des diverses pratiques
totalitaires
[Musique]
à 20 ans nicolas est à l'action
française est comme lui ils sont une
poignée de filles et garçons à préparer
leurs esprits et leur corps au retour de
la monarchie et pour patienter on leur
enseigne l'histoire politique comme le
combat de rue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le roi n'est pas son cousin même pas une
sembles et pourtant régine milite à la
nar chez les royalistes de gauche et
voilà je ne suis pas marché parce que je
suis royaliste je suis royaliste parce
que je suis monarchie c'est à dire que
c'est parce que je suis patriote et que
j'aime mon pays que je lui souhaite des
institutions qui permettent vraiment de
s'épanouir et de s'accomplir en france
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il ya des élections
présidentielles la moitié de la france à
l'impression des orphelines on serait
dans une monarchie comme en angleterre
les gouvernements pourraient se succéder
sans qu'ils aient toute une partie du
pays qu'ils aient l'impression d'aider
les faits nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
une monarchie élective
je voudrais que ce soit une monarchie
héréditaire
[Musique]